the New York Times reports that United
Airlines is defending its decision not
to let three girls board a plane because
they were wearing leggings the decision
created a social media frenzy after a
woman at the airport tweeted about it
several celebrities strongly criticized
the airline actress Patricia Arquette
wrote do you understand that you have
just made at least half of your
customers very unhappy comedian Sarah
Silverman threatened to change all her
flights to other airlines and William
Shatner posted a picture of himself
wearing some leggings all right mr.
Shatner very competent man Kris Van
Cleave is at the United counter at
Reagan National Airport near Washington
DC Chris good morning good morning now
these girls were flying on what's known
as past travel essentially flying for
free as relatives of a United employee
and because of that they're subject to a
stricter dress code than your average
flyer but by the time the airline
explained that the internet was in full
outraged mode and that has some saying
the airlines response is a textbook
example of how not to deal with a
Twitter crisis you notice trouble
started Sunday morning
[Applause]
when a gate agent in Denver told the
family of a young girl they could not
board their flight to Minneapolis unless
she covered up or changed her leggings
another passenger flying to Mexico
witnessed the commotion we heard her say
look I don't make the rules I just
enforce them
Shannon watts has four daughters she's
also a high-profile gun control activist
with more than 33 thousand Twitter
followers I don't think for women or
girls and this this young girl who was
10 or 11 looked like a normal little kid
watts who says to other teenage girls
were also denied boarding tweeted
since when does United police women's
clothing the airline replied that it had
the right to turn away passengers who
are barefoot are not properly clothed
other Twitter users received a similarly
brief response they seem to be arguing
with people including celebrities on
Twitter about this issue when the social
media controversy mushroomed into
unflattering headlines United's
communication staff went into crisis
mode on Sunday afternoon the company
revealed the affected passengers were
flying under a special program for
United employees that program has a
dress code
banning form-fitting lycra spandex tops
pants and dresses United stresses
regular paying customers who wear
leggings were welcomed on their planes
they bungled this one Frank wash cush PR
weeks news editor thinks the airline
waited too long to get the full story
out he also said it's tweets came across
as defensive and uncaring it's a really
difficult job and some companies do it
very well and some companies are still
learning other airlines have similar
policies they view employees and their
families traveling as pass flyers as
representatives of the airline when
they're on board the airplanes now one
of the girls was allowed to board the
flight after she changed her clothes
the other two are offered seats on a
later flight provided they were in line
with company policy Margaret Chris
thanks you wonder if they knew that that
was the company policy oh the kids who
are kids yeah but it seems like the
United skidding hammered but if you have
a dress code policy and your dress code
policy is stated maybe they need to
rethink the dress code policy since
everybody wears leggings but I think
it's wrong for them to get hammered when
this is a dress code policy and they
thought different [ __ ] employees or
in their friend
yeah regular paying customers there's
always two sides to every story